Paleontology.
I know what you're all thinking.
"Jurassic Park."
Maybe Ross from "Friends."
(Laughter)
Perhaps even Indiana Jones?
But that's archaeology.
Let me show you some real paleontology.
Now, first of all,
let's take a step back in time.
Not quite to the Jurassic,
at least not yet,
but to January 21, 2021,
when I received an email
about a curious discovery made
in Rutland in the Midlands.
As a paleontologist,
you can probably imagine,
I get countless messages and emails
from people saying,
"Oh, we've made a cool fossil discovery."
Being completely honest, most of the time,
it turns out to be, well,
a weird shaped rock,
(Laughter)
But, little did I know this email
would change my life.
The find had been made Rutland Water
Nature Reserve by Joe Davis,
who works for the Leicestershire
and Rutland Wildlife Trust
who run the reserve in partnership
with Anglian Water, who own the land.
Whilst doing some routine maintenance
in one of the Reserve's lagoons,
he'd lowered the water levels
and Joe had spotted
by chance this structure.
Unsure of what to make of it, he thought,
"Could this be a bit of old pipe, maybe?
Or perhaps,
is this a dinosaur skeleton?” he joked.
Luckily,
Joe thought to himself, "Well,
could it be an important discovery?"
So crucially, he sought expert advice.
When these photos pinged into my inbox,
I immediately recognized them
as large vertebrae
from the spine of an ichthyosaur,
or as it’s colloquially known
as a sea dragon.
Now, I do need to clear
that name up just a little bit,
because, I'm sorry to say,
they're not dragons.
Sorry.
They're also not swimming dinosaurs.
They’re not the Loch Ness
Monster on tour either.
And they're most definitely not,
as the BBC dubbed them
"Sea dragon dinosaur dolphin fossils."
(Laughter)
Terrible.
Ichthyosaurs are in fact
an awesome group
of ancient marine reptiles
that lived in the prehistoric seas
as dinosaurs reigned supreme on the land.
Like modern-day whales and dolphins,
they gave birth to live young,
and they breathed air.
Unfortunately, ichthyosaurs
went extinct around 90 million years ago.
Our Rutland ichthyosaur lived
during the early Jurassic,
around about 180 million years ago.
This is a time when Rutland
was deep underwater,
covered by an ancient tropical sea.
Now I spent most of my professional career
of around 14 years
studying thousands of ichthyosaurs.
And this has been a great pleasure
to travel around the world,
study lots and lots of ichthyosaurs.
And so when I received these photos,
I immediately knew that this could be
something very special indeed.
But of course, just looking at photos,
it's hard to know exactly whether
this is going to be something unique
or is it just a few vertebrae?
After speaking to fellow marine
reptile expert Dr. Mark Evans,
who was also sent details of the find,
we decided to visit the site in February.
And I led a mini excavation,
a bit of an exploratory dig
to see what we could uncover.
On a cold day in February,
where the ground was literally frozen
right beneath our feet,
after spending so much time
meticulously removing the Jurassic clay
from around the skeleton,
we were blown away
because we revealed what appeared to be
a gigantic skeleton
unlike anything ever found
in Britain before.
Clearly, this was a big deal.
But we had to be very quick
to contain our excitement.
Because due to the damp wintery conditions
and the fact that this
was a super fragile skeleton,
it meant it wasn't the right time
to collect this ichthyosaur.
So unfortunately, might seem
a little bit counterintuitive,
but we had to rebury the ichthyosaur.
And we had to cover it with plastic sheets
and then Jurassic clay.
Because you have to remember, this,
of course, is an active nature reserve.
And so the nature reserve,
they had to raise the water levels.
Then the ichthyosaur
went back under the water,
but it was actually protected.
And then waiting for what felt
like millions of years.
(Laughter)
In six months we were back on site,
but this time with a superb
team of paleontologists.
When we arrived on site,
we had to pick up where we left off.
And so we removed those plastic sheets,
remove the Jurassic clay,
and start to expose
some more of the skeleton.
We were overly ambitious in February.
We thought, based
on that little dig that we did,
the one-day excavation,
we thought, OK, we could probably
get the entire skeleton out of the ground
in just one week.
Yeah, we were wrong.
The skeleton was much larger,
more important and more complete
than any of us would have imagined.
And it doubled our time on site.
We spent 14 and a half days altogether,
spread over three weeks,
and this was also working very long hours,
from sunrise to sunset.
Whilst the team was excavating
the ichthyosaur,
we also had to look out
for all sorts of other pieces
in the surrounding matrix
of the ichthyosaur.
So in my hand here,
I'm actually holding one of the isolated
teeth from this ichthyosaur.
We also found hundreds
of these squid-like ammonites,
we found lots of fossil shells,
and these are all really important
because they help to build up
this bigger picture
of the ancient Jurassic ecosystem
in which this ichthyosaur lived.
The team also had to move fast as well.
This really was quite a race against time,
because once we exposed the skeleton,
there was more chance that it could
end up degrading further.
So team members like Dr. Emma Nicholls
here, had to apply a consolidant,
a thin glue that seeps into the bones
and helps them to become more robust
to remove the skeleton out of the ground.
Once we fully exposed the skeleton,
we then could eventually record all of our
measurements and get a full data set.
For example, like for the skull.
Nigel here, who I co-led
the excavation with,
so Nigel focused on
the conservation side of things,
ensuring that the ichthyosaur
remains safe and secure
throughout the entire excavation,
Nigel is holding
an ichthyosaur, a regular-size
ichthyosaur skull.
Look at the size comparison
to this Jurassic giant
that we're excavating.
Pretty phenomenal.
And this ichthyosaur,
I should say, that Nigel's holding,
this is actually of a species
I named after him a few years ago,
called Ichthyosaurs larkini.
Whilst on site,
one of the team members, Steve Dey,
created a wonderful photogrammetry model,
which, photogrammetry
is an interesting technique
where you take thousands of photos
and put them together and build
a three-dimensional model.
Now what you're looking at
first of all here,
is a base model that we made
back in February.
But watch this little video.
As we begin to zoom in,
you can see some of the spine
that we exposed in February.
It's pretty cool, it's three-dimensional.
But now watch, you can superimpose
the entire skeleton
that we'd revealed in the summer.
Here's the main excavation.
Now we can zoom in
and you can look at all
of the finer details of the bones
and the three-dimensionality of them.
And like magic, now we remove
the Jurassic clay.
Now we zoom out
and are able to see just
how complete this ichthyosaur is.
So you start from the very
tip of the snout
all the way down
to the penny-sized vertebrae.
Pretty cool.
And we're even able
to pick out individual bones
and look at them in three
dimensions like this.
This is the sort of techniques
that are sort of
revolutionizing paleontology.
We're able to capture all of this data
whilst the ichthyosaur sat in the ground.
So before we've even removed anything.
Now we've taken that out of the ground,
we still have this data,
and we can send that to our colleagues
all around the world.
Of course, now fully uncovered --
it’s me taking a nap --
It's time to literally get this Jurassic
giant out of the ground.
Much easier said than done
when you're dealing with such a complete
and very heavy fossil
weighing several tons.
The first port of call
was to create a trench
all the way around the skeleton.
And the reason for that is that we needed
to get right on underneath the skeleton
so that we could begin the process
of plaster jacketing.
So those white bits you can see
in the image, that's not snow,
although it was very cold
a few days on site,
that's actually plaster.
Plaster jacketing is an important process
in the field of paleontology.
We use these protective plaster jackets
that essentially care for and secure
the bones and the surrounding matrix
so that we can take them
out of the field and into the lab
so that we can analyze
the fossil and the matrix
and work out what's going on.
We also had to, for the bigger
skull block and the body block,
we also had to create a wooden frame
to help support the immense weight.
After various challenges on site,
we finally managed to remove
the entire skeleton
after dissecting it into several
more manageable blocks.
But this one block here,
which is the main body block,
this weighed one and a half tons.
It's actually being removed,
which is quite nice,
it's actually being removed by Joe Davis,
who found the ichthyosaur.
And this was an interesting
moment for the team
because it's quite an emotional moment,
because we'd spent and invested
so much time and energy
into this ichthyosaur excavation
that this moment captured that final piece
where we're removing this
from its final resting place,
180 million years ago.
On January 10, 2022,
this is almost one year after Joe
had made that incredible discovery,
Angling Water and the University
of Manchester
issued a joint press release
announcing the find.
Here’s Joe and I on the BBC Breakfast
Studio chatting about this discovery
and revealing it to the world.
Amazingly, this story went viral.
We were picked up on a multitude
of different platforms,
TV, radio, newspaper,
it went viral all across social media.
We were thrilled to bits
with this, it was amazing,
amazing response
about our beautiful ichthyosaur.
But one of the things is,
is why do you think exactly
did this ichthyosaur get so much interest?
First of all,
everybody loves a cool fossil,
especially when it's big
and it's complete.
So you've got a massive tick there.
But genuinely, this ichthyosaur
was an apex predator
at the very top of its food chain
in the Jurassic sea.
So again, another big tick.
And admittedly
the photograph is very cool,
although it is me again laying down.
(Laughter)
But on top of that, one thing
it's important to highlight
is the very fact that Britain
is the birthplace of ichthyosaurs.
This ichthyosaur specimen in the photo,
this was the first ichthyosaur specimen
brought to the attention of science,
found by Mary and Joseph Anning
more than 200 years ago
in the Lyme Regis on the Dorset coast.
Nowadays, finding ichthyosaur
fossils in the UK,
generally they're found on the Somerset,
the Dorset and the Yorkshire coastlines.
And that's because you have the constant
erosion of the foreshore and the cliffs.
You might be lucky to find, say,
the isolated one or two vertebrae
on the beach if you go looking.
But still finding a complete skeleton,
and especially anything large
on the coastline is incredibly rare.
This is why finding the Rutland
ichthyosaur in the center of the UK
in an unusual exposure
is so extraordinarily rare.
So what next for this
significant specimen?
Well, despite ongoing plans
to try to replace the Rutland Water
Nature Reserve with “Joerassic Park” --
(Laughter)
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
I apologize.
Compose myself.
No, the next major step
is for Nigel to clean and conserve
the entire skeleton.
And this is going to take
at least two years
to get to that point.
At that stage, then,
me and the rest of the team
are able to study the ichthyosaur
in as much detail as possible
and then prepare it
for its eventual display at Rutland,
where it will then attract,
hopefully millions of people
will travel around the world
to come and see this specimen,
marvel at this Jurassic giant,
and understand the hidden history
right beneath their feet.
What an incredible journey.
With most fossil finds,
there's always an element
of luck involved.
You know, being in the right place
at the right time.
People search their entire lives
for something like this
and never even come close.
The funny thing is, Joe wasn't
even looking for this.
He genuinely stumbled upon
this exceptional discovery.
At ten meters long,
the Rutland ichthyosaur
is the most complete skeleton
of a large prehistoric reptile
ever found in the UK.
This once-in-a-lifetime discovery
represents one of the greatest finds
in British paleontological history.
On a personal level,
leading this excavation
and revealing this Jurassic giant has been
one of the highlights of my career.
Thank you all very much for letting me
share this journey with you.
(Applause)